I mean you,
I have friends that are pretty overweight
and one that died pretty recently who
was really big and he just had this
feeling when he would meet people.
I mean you talked about it a little
bit. It was just obese, you know,
it was just this thing where you're
just, Oh, look at this enormous fat guy.
And then to go from that
to, oh, there's a guy,
there's a normal guy that's just a
guy that's 168 pound guy. Normal.
No difference between Hannah. I
tell Ya, I know we, we love to,
we love to beat up on fat people. We
love to turn it into a character defect.
But I gotta tell you virtually every fat
person that I know or that I've taken
care of, they are not disproportionally
eating more than their peers.
So in some cases, yes,
but not on balance it,
the problem is that they simply
do everything incorrectly,
metabolically, you know, so their body
is functioning correctly and it's,
you know, and it's exempt.
There's a genetic component.
I think there are dietary exacerbations.
I think certainly not
exercising makes things worse.
So there are lots of predisposing factors,
but at the end of the day,
what's happening is when you and I eat
like let's, let's take a meal that,
that like if you had pancakes,
bacon and scrambled eggs,
that would be like a really good mix of,
that'd be a third carbs, a third protein,
a third fat. So that's like a shit ton of
nutrient, right? If you were, I ate that.
Yeah, it probably wouldn't be that
good for us. But like we, you know,
let's say we just finished a workout or
something like we're going to partition
such that that glycogen will first and
foremost go to replace the muscle and
liver stores of glycogen because we have
bigger muscles and our muscles are more
insulin sensitive.
We can actually disproportionately
put more glycogen into our muscles,
into the leg muscles, cause you'll have
done that, run up the hills. Right. And,
and then furthermore,
when we want to recruit energy again,
we'll have the ability to actually go
back and get fat. Especially, you know,
in other words,
break down fat at lower ATP demands than
necessarily always going to glycogen.
So, in other words, we partition fuel
in a smarter way. And these patients,
I mean you can measure this clinically
using something called rer and of course
doing other blood tests,
like they just, they just,
they can't break down their own fat.
So their body is essentially broken in
that regard. And that can be fixed with,
with diet. It's a hard problem because
the way I explained it to people as,
and so clinically I'm not
interested in weight loss, right?
I mean that's just not, I'm much more
interested in longevity and yeah,
sometimes weight loss comes with that.
But I like if I ever get stuck doing,
you know, weight loss, like I'll, I'll,
I'm doing the wrong thing for my interest.
But, um, the way I say to people when
they want to lose weight is, look,
you don't want to lose weight.
You want to lose fat. Let's,
let's be very clear on our semantics.
It weight is irrelevant, right?
Unless you're a cyclist or some
athlete for whom the actual scale means
something. But for, for people like us,
it's you want to lose fat, not wait.
And then when you say you want to lose
fat, what does that mean in English? Well,
do you want fewer fat cells or do
you want each fat cell to be smaller?
Those are totally different questions.
If you want fewer fat
cells have liposuction,
but we know that that doesn't fix you
metabolically. So if you want fewer,
if you want to be less fat, you
have to have smaller fat cells. Now,
a fat cell conceptually has
two inputs and one output.
So now I say,
let's reframe the question.
You've got a room with a hundred people
in it. You want fewer people in the room.
What has to happen? More people have
to leave the room, then enter the room.
So similarly, if you have a fat
cell and you want it to be less fat,
you've got to get more fat out of it.
Then enters it and the fat that exits
the cell exits via a process called
lipolysis and the inputs to a fat cell
or something called De Novo Lipogenesis,
which is turning carbohydrates
into fat and reassess aerification,
which is turning fat like in a free fatty
acid into a triglyceride back into a
fat cell. Each of those three
doors is controlled by hormones.
And so the purpose of nutrition or fasting
or exercise or drugs or hormones or
all these things is to manipulate those
hormones in the direction of what I call
negative fat flux or what
would be referred to in the
literature as fat balance,
negative fat balance. And the hormones
that drive that are are many insulin,
hormone sensitive lipase,
testosterone, estrogen,
cortisol being the five most
important in my opinion. Uh,
maybe someone will disagree with that,
but I think those are the five that
rule the roost. And so, you know,
how do you manipulate those?
Well,
insulin seems to be the most important
of the five and there's no better way to
lower insulin than to not eat.
So the first thing that happened to that
dude who went 382 days without anything
but water and minerals, is he
basically had very low insulin levels.
In fact, once he got into raging Ketosis,
which he got into by about day seven,
his insulin came up only to prevent
him from going into Ketoacidosis,
which was what would happen if he had
no insulin response. In other words,
if he was a type one diabetic,
he would have died if ketoacidosis,
because he wouldn't have had the insulin
to regulate the uptick of ketones.
But if you are, I did this
because we have a normal pancreas.
We would actually remake just enough
insulin to suppress ketogenesis and keep
that Beta hydroxybutyrate level in the,
you know,
kind of in the neighborhood of probably
seven or eight millimolar as opposed to
getting north of 12 to 15 which
is when you get into trouble.
So you know,
how do you manipulate insulin?
Nutrition is the first way.
If you can't fast,
the next best thing is
to reduce carbohydrates.
Carbohydrates obviously are
the most insulinogenic of food,
although protein can be quite
insular agentic as well.
It has a different response.
Um,
and then that's when you start to think
about these other things. You know,
I've seen patients where they just can't
lose weight and I watch what they're
doing and they're doing everything right,
but they just can't lose weight.
But then you notice their
cortisol levels through the roof.
It's hard to get rid of fat when
you have hot lots of cortisol.
Cortisol is a very anabolic hormone
to fat in a very catabolic hormone to
muscle, which is the exact opposite
of what we want to stoss. Drone,
of course is the exact opposite.
Testosterone is catabolic to
fat but anabolic to muscle. Um,
and then of course,
you know,
women have a harder time because
once women go through menopause,
they lose all the estrogen
and all the testosterone.
And so now they lose two hormones that
play a very important role in regulating
this. So for these people that are
having the issue with cortisol levels,
that's exacerbated by stress,
right?
So stress actually exacerbates
your weight gain. Absolutely.
That's interesting. In addition
to a whole bunch of other stuff,
literally eat the same diet and gain more
weight because of stress. Absolutely.
Wow. Again, hormones are what's
driving fuel partitioning.
You know, you're responsible for what
you put in your mouth, but in many ways,
at that point, like the hormones take
over and decide where it's going. Wow.